the most traditional of british
businesses now struggling with energy
costs so high they might have to close
altogether i was trying to get a renewal
quote for energy and it was just really
casually sent back to me and it was
900 pound a month more expensive um
and that for us like small independent
business is absolutely crippling yeah
it's one of those things it could be the
nail in the coffin for
for this business or other businesses
like ours
big manufacturers like the steel
industry aren't immune they're looking
to this man business secretary quasi
quatang for help lukewarm on a price cap
for energy intensive industry today but
reassuring bosses he's in talks with the
treasury to find a solution there's
absolutely no possibility of a price cap
for industry no can you be clear about
that i'm what i'm very clear about is
that we need to get through this
situation it's a difficult situation gas
prices electricity prices are at very
high levels right across the world and
of course i'm speaking with government
colleagues particularly in the treasury
to try and see a way through this yet
just minutes after this interview an
unprecedented slap down from a treasury
source exposing a rift at the heart of
government in a highly unusual move a
treasury source accused mr kuatang of
making things up and denied there are
any talks happening right now about a
financial solution this issue is so
complex that any financial support could
cost the government and therefore
taxpayers millions of pounds and
remember this is a chancellor already
aware of how much public money he spent
not keen to add to that total that's not
to say help won't come but what it looks
like and when is still up in the air and
more trouble for the business secretary
followed soon after your planet energy
another energy company on the brink of
collapse pure planet energy which has
250 000 customers about to fold labour
says ministers are too focused on
political rows businesses are under
enormous pressure families are really
feeling the squeeze of this cost of
living crisis everything's more
expensive
and what do we get from the government
the prime minister has gone off on
holiday uh goodness knows where the
chancellor is today and the business
secretary just seems to be making it up
as he goes along on television this
morning i mean it's just utter chaos
all quiet at number 11 and at the
business department today but this is
the calm before the storm businesses say
they're on the brink they can't wait
anymore but with parliament in recess
and the prime minister away will
ministers put aside their row to agree
support or will the industry be left to
cope with months of uncertainty alone
kate mccann sky news